madame zourabichvili bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous
c'est d'abord quel est votre sentiment
quand vous voyez les combats qui se
poursuivent en ukraine pour une
troisième semaine la destruction les
civils qui fuient les troupes russes qui
sont aux portes de kiev
d'abord c'est un sentiment de déjà vu et
puis pour nous comme pour l'ukraine
l'adhésion par là aussi ce n'est pas une
nouveauté nous avons vécu cela dans
l'histoire plusieurs fois au début du
siècle dernier contre la première
indépendance géorgienne comme
ukrainienne a été
ensuite renversé par les armes et rouge
et ensuite nous avons vécu
l'indépendance de 91 les
séparatistes ont été utilisés contre
l'indépendance et enfin nous avons eu la
guerre de 2008
le conflit que le roi au jeu donc c'est
du déjà vu et en même temps c'est une
très grande admiration pour
l'extraordinaire résistance du peuple
ukrainien qui est quelque chose que l'on
a réellement jamais
toute organisation
face à quelque chose qui apparaissait au
départ à tout le monde comme une
agression totale à laquelle personne ne
peut résister et qui avait s'achever en
quelques jours est en réalité en bois au
bout de trois semaines que les forces
sont en quelque sorte d'équilibré
que la superpuissance militaire russe
n'est plus les pas si super puissance
que ça et que la cariou rites et
ukrainiennes en ouvrir moyens est
aujourd'hui
compensée par l'extrême détermination de
défendre son pays mais à quel prix non
quand même quand on voit toute cette
destruction
armes et le prix il n'a pas été choisi
par le cren
et quand on défend son territoire son
pays ce qui est quelque chose que l'on
connaît et c'est ça que l'on voit à
l'oeuvre il y a une volonté de survivre
et de
car survivre sa propre liberté
d'ailleurs pas seulement sa propre
liberté je dois dire que nous nous
considérons que les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui se bat aussi pour nous et il
se bat aussi pour l'europe et peut-être
pour le monde parce que l'avenir de ce
que sera la relation de l'art si demain
on reste du monde dépendra probablement
de l'issue de ces combats ouais vous
disiez que c'est un peu une répétition
aujourd'hui en ukraine de ce qu'il a
déjà fait en géorgie plusieurs analystes
craignent justement qu'il ne s'arrête
pas à l'ukraine est ce que vous vous
pensez que ce serait possible qu'il
refasse la même chose en géant jaune je
crois que ça dépend beaucoup
de l'issue de cette guerre ce que l'on
voit c'est ce que certains experts
militaires connaissent c'est à dire que
dans ce genre de conflit les plus forts
s'affaiblissent plus le conflit dure il
est plus faible et se renforce et c'est
ça que le roi l'oeuvre et je crois que
personne ne peut donner l'issue de ce
conflit mais que de l'issue de ce
conflit dépendra beaucoup à l'avenir de
tous nos pays qui sont pourtour de la
russie et pas seulement ceux qui sont
aux portuaires vous avez officiellement
réitérer votre demande d'adhésion à
l'europe
esque pourquoi c'est si important pour
vous et jusqu'où vous êtes prête à aller
ou jusqu'où la géorgie est prête à aller
pour l'obtenir parce qu'on sait ce qui
ce qui ce qui vous attend en fait ans et
que vous pouvez déclencher encore une
colère de vladimir poutine le choix de
la mesure où l'europe qui datent pas
d'aujourd'hui date de bien avant la
russie il a été réitérée au moment où la
géorgie a retrouvé son indépendance en
1918 que en 91 et aujourd'hui il est
inscrit dans notre constitution et il
est soutenu par 80% de la population
donc c'est un choix existentiels nous
n'avons pas d'autres perspectives
nous sommes par nos valeurs et par notre
situation géopolitique nous sommes liés
à l'europe et c'est notre famille donc
c'est pas quelque chose que poutine ou
quelqu'un d'autre au décider à notre
place est-ce que vous avez l'impression
contre l'occident en fait suffisamment
que lille l'occident est à la hauteur
des attentes avec l'ukraine parce qu'en
géorgie en 2008 on a un peu laissé faire
vladimir poutine c'est un cheminement
plusieurs reprises l'europe l'occident
n'a pas été
réactif on a trop pris en compte
justement le narrative russe qu'il y
avait des provocations autour d'eux
qu'il ne faisait que céder aux
provocations répondre et on a essayé
d'être complaisant en espérant apaiser
la russie
cette politique d'apaisement n'a pas
fonctionné elle n'a fait qu'encourager
est la conséquence c'est aujourd'hui
c'est le cred et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'ukraine réussi ce miracle de l'essayer
les yeux de l'occident de montrer où est
la véritable provocation ou est la
véritable agression
et de l'unir en se faisant les européens
autour d'elle les européens et les
américains et le continent américain et
je sais qu'au canada il y a beaucoup
d'ukrainiens mais c'est bien qu'ils
pensent aujourd'hui à leur patrie et je
voudrais leur dire qu'ils peuvent être
très fiers
mais jusqu'où vous pensé combien de
temps vous pensez que c'est l'ukrainien
peuvent tenir face à cette machine eh
bien je crois que personne n'aurait pu
dire au début du conflit qu'ils auraient
eu deux ou trois semaines les calculs
des experts y compris américains je
crois que c'était trois jours et on voit
qu'au bout de trois semaines non
seulement ils ont tenu mais la russie on
est réduit aujourd'hui à demander des
armes et des rations alimentaires pour
ses soldats à la chine
alors je crois qu'on peut se dire que
tout est permis et que personne ne peut
aujourd'hui faire des prédictions sur ce
qu'il va arriver on ne peut que soutenir
le craignent que soutenir les ukrainiens
aussi longtemps que le jugerons que la
diplomatie n'a pas donné les résultats
qu'ils peuvent en attendre et à cesser
le feu ou à un accord qui serait pour
eux c'est top parce que pour vous il va
aller jusqu'au bout vladimir poutine en
ukraine
malheureusement je moi je ne sais pas ce
qu'on va les outils probablement qu'il
ira jusqu où il veut aller et où il veut
aller ça va dépendre des ukrainiens de
soutien qui vont recevoir de l'extérieur
je soutien qu'ils reçoivent de
l'extérieur c'est ça qui fait le rapport
des forces et c'est le rapport des
forces qui détermine si la diplomatie
ensuite de prendre le relais et obtenir
un accord qui soit un vrai compromis
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si la russie
est prête à un compromis
très bien madame jours à bischwiller
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris ces quelques
minutes avec nous très éclairante merci
merci